one consequence of Hollywood being
dominated by superheroes and franchises
is that by the time you're my age you've
seen about 6,000 action seconds some are
spectacular many are not and it's pretty
easy to distinguish between the two
because the reaction is physical as
adrenaline then released into your
system or not are you gripping your arm
rests or not after watching all these
set pieces
I think we've sort of been forced to
develop an intuitive sophistication
about them there are no shortcuts to
thrilling an audience that's absolutely
drowning in this stuff we recognize and
champion good work when we see and feel
it I think that's the secret to the
success of franchises like Mission
Impossible Fast & Furious and John wick
these are movies that are committed to
well choreographed well edited real
action okay not always real
Tom Cruise understands exactly what it's
offering the three or four genuinely
creative set pieces with a serviceable
plot that doesn't take itself too
seriously and a few charismatic actors
can be a really fun movie going
experience well worth the price of a
ticket
in fact this formula I think in many
ways defines the strategy of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe some of those movies
are undoubtedly better than this some
are unfortunately worse but they've
tried their best to hew to this baseline
and I think it's worked out pretty well
for them anyone else every ingredient
matters of course but the Marvel set
pieces have been really consistent by
and large and they're probably the
things that I remember most when I think
back on these movies now I know there's
a certain amount of fatigue these days
about superhero films I feel that way
too
more and more but you know if I ever
think back to my expectations as a kid
for what big screen superhero team-up
fights would be like I mean this
definitely exceeds them there's a lot
going on here that you don't understand
Darkseid you'd say that
the sad part about this is that as a kid
I read DC Comics not Marvel Comics and
unfortunately the DC extended universe
set pieces leave a lot to be desired
there are a lot of reasons for this I
think that people have explored before
Zack Snyder's preference for stylized
coloring versus the more muted
cinematography of the MCU the overuse of
super slow motion and ridiculous virtual
camera moves like this but there are a
few other things I want to point out
that I think make a bigger difference
when it comes to superhero set pieces
the first is that physics matters we all
know that superheroes do a lot of absurd
things half the shots that Ironman takes
would be fatal blows but people have an
intuitive sense for weight and velocity
and
which is why any camera action usually
gets a more visceral response from
audiences the physics are absolutely
real this doesn't mean that all CG is
bad but if you're going to use CG it's a
good idea to pay a lot of attention to
the cues that people pick up in the
first set piece of Winter Soldier for
example the Russo brothers do a great
job at gauging Captain America's
strength level for the audience with
only a few shots they lace these in with
real hand-to-hand combat to enhance the
realism or take spider-man a heavily CG
character it's easy to establish his
physics because he's swinging on elastic
bands and it's a different type of
physics than Iron Man's for the Hulk's
too often in DC movies the physics just
don't matter or the camera is doing
something that makes everything feel
weightless taking away the real force of
a punch for example and there's not
enough difference between the heroes for
the audience to really feel the power
levels nothing is graceful or tactical
it's all just brute force which brings
me to my second point
this can seemed in this use powers
creatively first time for everything
[Music]
it's not always the case but there's a
good number of times in the Marvel
movies where powers interact off of one
another in ways that you can't predict
capacity how about that or they take
something routine like someone bailing
from a car and just go
the extra step ABC films every character
is a blunt instrument only doing the
most obvious thing which in Superman's
case is usually punishing this
frustrates me so much because Superman
has a laundry list of powers there has
to be some way for him to combine them
in a creative way to solve a problem or
defeat a clever villains I know a good
filmmaker can figure it out finally the
one thing that Marvel is really good at
is the ability to slip character moments
into the cracks of big set pieces every
action scene has its pauses when
everything stops and the characters get
to say a line or two I am live for the
simple changes like how much this is
here are the things that Marvel
characters say on those pauses we're
still friends right more handsome in
person and he didn't invite me
you man who is laying with the rascal
Berrien because one time you got a hard
kid are you from Queens Brooklyn now
here are the things that DC characters
say I'm gonna stop you you ever estimate
yourself we'll see about that
next time they shine your light musk I
don't go Ola crafting good set-pieces
won't solve all the problems plaguing
the DC EU they can't make for a good
movie alone but I think you'd be
surprised how much people forgive when
they've had a genuinely bracing
experience at the theater eventually the
people behind the DC EU will figure it
out until then I'm afraid it's just
gonna be a whole lot of this
[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this episode was brought to you
by Squarespace if you want to make a
website and you want it to be a really
easy process Squarespace has some
beautiful award-winning designer
templates to choose from that makes that
process super simple
it's got 24-hour customer service no
upgrades nothing to install no patches
ever and picking your domain name is
really easy construct your free trial
squarespace.com and if you use the offer
code nerdwriter you can get 10% of your
first purchase thanks guys I'll see you
next time